Щодня в Україні реєструють сотні нових випадків
захворювання на коронавірусну інфекцію.
Кількість хворих то зменшується до двохсот п'ятдесяти на день,
то знову майже вдвічі зростає.
Загалом за понад два місяці жорсткого карантину
в Україні захворіли понад 22 тисячі людей.
Третина з них одужали.
Від початку пандемії держава обіцяє українцям повністю безкоштовне лікування.
У цьому під час скайп-конференції Deutsche Welle
запевнила й очільниця
Національної служби здоров’я.
Тобто повний перелік послуг,
який може знадобитись конкретному пацієнту,
пов'язаний з підозрою, або підтверджений випадок СOVID-19
повністю сплачений державою.
Пацієнту не потрібно нічого доплачувати.
Так в теорії. Натомість пацієнти,
які вже пройшли лікування,
або ще хворіють на COVID-19 і лікуються,
розповідають DW дещо інше.
Це киянин Віктор, одесит Шахін та чернівчанка Аліса.
Самоізоляція Віктора завершилась близько місяця тому.
Після тривалого лікування, шпиталізації і, врешті, двох негативних контрольних тестувань
21- річний чоловік має статус здорового
і може спокійно прогулюватись улюбленим парком.
Віктор досі не має уявлення, де підхопив коронавірус.
Адже від початку запровадження карантину обмежив контакти з друзями, походи в магазин...
Перші симптоми з'явилися наприкінці березня.
Його шпиталізували до столичної інфекційної лікарні.
В цілому все було безкоштовно, але все одно доводилось докуповувати,
адже щось в лікарні закінчувалось і не постачалось.
Якісь додатки в крапельницю або якісь імпортні замінники, які кращої якості.
це ніхто не змушує купувати,
і не треба це робити в лікарняній аптеці,
але все одно доводиться щось купувати.
Тож за весь час я витратив
не більше 1200 гривень.
Аби якось скрасити одноманітні дні в палаті,
Віктор фільмував своє життя в лікарні, зокрема,
її аскетичні умови та харчування.
Це було не дуже смачно, в основному це був переварений рис і сосиска.
Це було найкраще м'ясо,
яке могло б бути в тих умовах.
Інколи шматок м'яса можна було виловити у борщі.
Але натомість не було проблем з передачами.
Хоча, каже, суперумов від медицини, яка завжди була недофінансованою, він і не очікував.
Компенсувала всі негативні спогади - професійна команда лікарів,
яка ним опікувалась та вилікувала.
На запитання, чи було лікування від коронавірусу безкоштовним,
-річний одесит Шахін Асадов відповідає спершу сатиричним сміхом.
Безкоштовно нічого не було - я для вас щось нове сказав?
Я все лікування - від і до - пройшов за свій рахунок.
Чоловік прилетів з Берліна за день до закриття Україною кордонів.
І вже наступного дня у нього різко піднялась температура.
Перше тестування виявилось негативним,
тож його разом з дружиною відпустили додому.
Утім, такі симптоми, як кашель та висока температуране не зникали
і лише за 10 днів його таки госпіталізували.
В соціальних мережах він розповідав друзям про своє лікування.
Лікарі прописали препарати, які коштують нереально великих грошей.
Нереально. І насправді я навіть не знаю, чого очікувати далі.
Йдеться про препарат "Біовен", який не входить в перелік безкоштовних
і рекомендованих МОЗом засобів для лікування коронавірусу.
Та саме його виписали одеські лікарі Шахіну.
Лікування виявилось хоча й дорогим, але ефективним.
Більше 30 тисяч гривень, це не маленькі гроші,
але просто сам факт того, що скрізь писали, що всі хворі на коронавірус
будуть лікуватись за рахунок держави.
Я на собі цього не відчув.
Через день приходила медсестра з листочком.
Там були написані препарати, які мені були необхідні
для подальшого лікування,  і я їх купував.
Давав свою банківську картку медсестрам разом з пін-кодом
і вони йшли закуповували.
На безкоштовне лікування взагалі не можуть розраховувати ті пацієнти,
які відмовилися від шпиталізації.
На це свідомо пішла чернівчанка Аліса,
бо не хотіла займати лікарняні ліжка,
яких і так не вистачає.
Чернівецька область і досі має найбільшу кількість хворих - це понад 3 тисячі осіб.
Я лікувалась амбулаторно, всі ліки я купувала за власний рахунок.
Декілька тисяч гривень мені це обійшлось.
Ці надбавки, які нам видали. Так би мовити, короновірусні надбавки,
половина цієї суми пішла на лікування. Як мінімум.
Аліса - лікар швидкої допомоги. На власні очі бачила важких хворих на COVID-19
та те, як хвороба швидко прогресує.
Очевидно, від інфікованих пацієнтів і підхопила хворобу.
Зараз дівчина чекає на результати другого контрольного тесту.
Втім, і досі продовжує кашляти, а відчутя смаку та запаху,
які втратила місяць тому, ще так і не повернулися.
Про свою хворобу також повідмола у соцмережах, аби не лише розповісти про її перебіг,
але й нагадати українцям про гуманне ставлення, до тих хто інфікувався.
Мені колеги з Данії говорили, знайомі, що там,
коли старша людина захворіє на коронавірус, вона могла написати про це
на заборі власного будинку і люди приносили фрукти, овочі.
У нас,  коли були випадки,  їм кидали через забор записки
"вийдеш з будинку - приб'єм".
Вибачте, але це дикість, це аморально.
Люди налякані. Це жахливо.
Треба не боятись і проявляти людяність, і розуміння.
Не треба панікувати, але треба розуміти, що це серйозно.
Нині хворих на COVID-19  лікують згідно з національним протоколом,
який затвердив МОЗ на основі світового досвіду.
До нього входять протималярійні, антиретровірусні препарати.
Втім, самих цих ліків не достатньо,
а інколи вони взагалі протипоказані пацієнтам.
Розповідає DW лікарка-інфекціоніст з Чернівців.
Вона звинувачує владу у маніпуляції та неправильній комунікації з пацієнтами.
Біля пацієнтів залишаємось лише ми.
В костюмах, ходимо біля пацієнтів лише ми.
Губернатора там немає.
А такі заяви, що все вам буде безкоштовно,
не можна робити в цей час.
І люди - були такі ситуації, - коли висловлювали агресію до нас.
Наразі  Національна служба здоров'я виплатила лікарням
за надання допомоги пацієнтам майже 163 мільйони гривень.
Окрім препаратів, що входять до національного протоколу,
пацієнти отримують безоплатно ПЛР тестування
лабораторні та інструментальні дослідження, як от аналіз крові та сечі,
інтенсивну терапію та підключення до апаратів ШВЛ.
Повний перелік послуг вказаний на сайті служби.
Тож врешті-решт, виходить, не лікування від коронавірусу в цілому,
а лише те що передбачено Міністерством охорони здоров'я
має бути безкоштовним.